bill and ted what have you got to say
for yourselves
be excellent to each other and party on
dudes
welcome to your weekly ticket
it's official bill and ted face the
music the third bill and ted movie will
be available to watch
at home via digital platforms like
fandango now voodoo
and in select theaters starting
september 1st
alex winter revealed during a comic con
at home panel over the weekend
that the sequel was 10 years in the
making and at one point
wasn't even going to happen also keanu
gushes over the new film saying
i can't feel or laugh or do anything
like the way that working on bill and
ted does
and working with alex dave franco is set
to play robert van winkle
better known as vanilla ice in a new
biopic about the rapper
the film titled to the extreme was
revealed in january 2019
but it is unclear when filming will
begin however franco opened up to
insider about the project saying
rob is such a sweet and intelligent guy
and he's super helpful in the process of
getting
all the details correct and making us
privy to information the public doesn't
know
just talking to him i can't help but
think about the rabbit holes i'm going
to go
down to get ready for the roll and sonic
the hedgehog 2 will be getting a
theatrical release
in 2022 ben schwartz who voiced the
character in the movie
confirmed the video game sequel on his
twitter account writing
sonic 2 is officially coming to theaters
april 8th
2022 jeff fowler who directed the 2020
film is expected to return to direct the
next movie
today we're highlighting rotten tomatoes
300 essential films you can watch
right now and i'm joined by alex vo
editor at rotten tomatoes
alex you got to help us out uh we got a
lot of movies on this list what do you
think are the
two essential that we should watch right
now uh i'll preface this by saying
that this list used to be 200 movies and
every year we would debate like which
five essential movies would we take on
which five do we take out
and at the end of the day i would feel
like well the movies we took out
i kind of want them on the list so this
year for this year's update we increase
it to 300 movies so
the two movies i'll pick the first movie
i'll pick is a movie that's always
been on a list since the beginning and
that's going to be drive from
2011. um it's probably my favorite movie
of all time
i remember when it was first coming out
i'm like it stars ryan gosling
has carrie mulligan in it it's a los
angeles story with a synthwave
soundtrack
directed by a weird danish guy i don't
see how this isn't going to be the best
movie ever
and i saw it and i was like that was the
best movie ever
and i say that all the time every time i
watch a movie i'm like i hope this is
the best movie ever and
it never pans out dry was the only time
where it actually happened
and what's your other film uh and then
the second film
is 1990s total recall with the arnold
schwarzenegger
it's a movie i try to watch every year
or every other year
uh i first saw it probably way too early
i think it was like
eight years old when i first saw it um
and it just completely blew my mind
it really opened up my horizon of what
like
movies could be you know in terms of
like action cinema
how subversive it could be and just
science fiction and just how
weird and scary and violent and just
hilarious
movies can be um yeah i think it stands
the test of time
people are still talking about the
ending of that one not just if you
haven't seen it
there's still people debating on the
where the story
is at the ending and that's one of those
that's one of the great things about
that movie is that
whether you're for this side or that
side
you can't really prove either way so it
just kind of works
both ways kind of same with like blade
runner is a decade or replicant or not
there's ample evidence for both sides
either way and you know blade
blade runner 2049 kind of touches upon
that as well yeah
and blade runner is on uh the essential
300 list
yeah it should be as it should be so i
you know i enjoy
both of those movies but what what do
you think makes them essential to rotten
tomatoes
the first and foremost is that each
movie on the list is
certified fresh because of raw tomatoes
we're a data driven company and we
collect reviews
certified fresh is sort of the label
that we give to movies when they hit a
certain score it's 75 percent or higher
on a two millimeter
after a certain number of reviews for
most movies it's 80 reviews
for smaller limited or classic movie is
40 reviews so
each so as much as i you know have my
personal choices
on the list each movie is vetted by
critics
each week has been seen enough by
critics and enough and
enough of those critics approve of the
movie um
and what we try to do is really try to
make this list for everybody it has
action
anime sci-fi but also the classics you
know
also romantic comedy so no matter where
you're coming in from
what you're into you'll be able to
broaden your horizons with the list that
was our goal
how should someone plan on catching up
on all these essential films uh you know
the the earliest movie on this list
is the cabinet of dr caligari from 1920
meaning that it you know celebrated its
100th year anniversary this year
um and with the list we really try to
hit every sort of
segment and era and moment in cinema
history
and what i would do personally is
pick a movie from each decade and you
know from the 1920s 1930s 94 just kind
of pick the ones that you haven't seen
that sound the most interesting
and just kind of it's just ten movies
right there and just kind of
pick away at the list that way all right
nice
um well thank you very much alex vo
available to watch at home on friday
tijuana jackson purpose over
prison for me you know i i just believe
that if you're gonna be a life coach you
got to be a life coach 247 because life
is a full-time job why you always got to
speak in parables you know how many
travel permits wants to
take off i'll think about it what you
mean you're gonna think about it do you
need me to speak in parables too
tijuana jackson is a man determined to
move beyond his checkered past and
achieve his ambition of becoming a
world-renowned motivational speaker
when asked to be the subject of a
10-minute student film tj leaps at the
opportunity
10 minutes turns into 10 hours and 10
hours becomes 10 life-altering days of
courage and
inspiration determined to be more than a
statistic with a pipe dream
tj stops at nothing to earn the respect
of his family and crush who is currently
his probation officer
by becoming the success story they
claimed he'd never be
the film stars romani malko regina hall
and tammy roman
and available to watch at home today
deep blue c3
hey all you shark week fans out there
welcome back
it's our third summer here at little
happy an abandoned fishing village in
the mozambique channel
sharks return here each year their home
like
ours is under attack from climate change
deep blue c3 follows a group of
scientists who inhabit a remote undersea
laboratory for the purpose of conducting
experiments on sharks
when a huge storm floods the lab the
group suddenly find themselves fighting
the very specimens they've created
in the sequel a conservationist
discovers that scientists are once again
using the sharks for experiments
with potentially deadly consequences
alright well that is it for today make
sure to check out that full list of
rotten tomatoes 300
essential films we'll leave a link below
and let us know which one is your
favorite
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you